this is the set right here so this is
how it looks through production lights
what you don't see is all of this
I'm sat for years talking about my
feelings and this is the last time and
it's a little bittersweet today
Christine Brown taking Sister Wives fans
behind the scenes enormous weight has
been lifted I'm watching the episodes is
hard I like my life so much better now
yeah and that life's looking pretty
different following her split from Cody
Brown after more than 25 years together
I just saw glint in your eye you're
excited about getting out I'm excited
about there's a hope for a future and
not to mention a brand new change of
scenery Christine's now living in Utah
closer to many of her other family
members this is is the last day I am on
the set in Flagstaff
and it is a little Bittersweet so now
Christine's taking to tick tock to
celebrate the mouse shown with a Parting
Gift a rare look at where the cast does
their confessionals I don't care what
he's saying I'm not being mean a
trademark filming location for the
reality Series this is the couch
right here that I've sat on
for years talking about the show and
discussing my feelings that this is the
set right here so this is how it looks
through production lights what you don't
see is all of this
and here we go that's the side where can
we keep our clothes and this is where
the crew sits the cameras are usually
right there it's really raw and open and
we're super vulnerable and just super
honest I don't like a lot of hard
conversations and our life is full of
hard conversations if this is where the
producer sits
and it's in a garage actually so there's
the door of the garage but this is the
entire set and this has been
where I have sat for years talking about
my feelings as Christine notes in the
caption she's traveled back and forth
every other week for the past year and
now she's so glad to finally settle in
Utah this is the last time and it's a
little bittersweet today
this is it by Flagstaff I am telling my
Sister Wives that I'm leaving Cody and
she's not the only one in need of a
fresh start we've been separated for
several months what
so are you separated yes we are
separated Janelle and Mary also going
their separate ways with Cody so now the
patriarch's down to one wife Robin who's
the only one he was legally married to
so for us plural merge doesn't work
for us marriage doesn't work and it's
all coming to head in the three part
Sister Wives one-on-one special do you
think if Christine didn't object that
Mary and Cody would have gotten back
together uh yeah because when Cody says
and thinks that type of stuff it usually
happens
that's a lie that's not me and I would
never do that like me was what I was
supposed to do and everything and that
felt great and now though yeah I get to
be done
[Music]
thank you